the eye team has obtained evidence in a
murder case against two teens we thank
you for joining us at five i'm bryan
loftis
and i'm denise valdez video photos
receipts text messages
prosecutors point to a trail of evidence
the i-team's vanessa murphy first broke
this story and she's here now with what
the i-team has uncovered
denise and brian sierra halseth is just
16 years old aaron guerrero
is 18. cell phone video shows them
talking about a murder before they were
taken into custody in utah
police say their parents had told them
they couldn't see each other anymore
their plan was to run away together to
california
then daniel howell said sierra's father
was found
dead back to our youtube channel
after turning day three after
murdering somebody whoa don't put that
on the camera
it was worth it the i-team obtained
text messages between sierra halseth and
her grandmother
this would be daniel halces mom she
texts sierra that she's trying to get a
hold of her dad and asked
where he is sierra's response his phone
has been acting up it should be fixed by
tomorrow
no worries with a smiley face this
continued until friday daniel halsey's
mother realizing
something wasn't right eventually two
friends visit his home
and find his body by that point police
say the teens had left and just taking a
look at the many photos from inside the
home
the crime scene was not cleaned up
that's part of the trail of
evidence prosecutors are now pointing to
back to you
and vanessa sierra houses mother is
someone who's been in the public eye
right what have we heard from her or
really anyone else in the halseth family
yeah elizabeth helseth is a former
nevada state senator she has not spoken
publicly about the allegations against
her daughter
she and daniel halseth had divorced and
she since remarried
as for daniel halsett's side of the
family before we aired this story
i reached out to a family member who's
been the sort of point person
she says the family is declining to
comment at this time but we certainly
you know wanted them to know that we'd
be reporting more on this case
this whole situation obviously is tragic
and we want to be
respectful as we report this vanessa
thank you for that